hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast community pharmacy based
disease management programs using
point-of-care tests presented by zonal
CLEP sir associate professor a
University of Nebraska Medical Center
I'm Lexus cross of laberd's and I'll be
our moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's lab
Riggs is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Custer I will now turn the presentation
over to him Thank You Alexis it's an
honor to be here talking a little bit
today about some of the work we've done
around community pharmacy based disease
management programs utilizing
point-of-care tests so just some quick
housekeeping some of the disclosures
that I have there let's just jump in and
let's talk about community pharmacies
and why why we started working in
community pharmacies and I think the
first thing is that maybe surprises some
people is that there are about 60,000
community pharmacies in the United
States so I mean if we think about what
you know what is a community pharmacy
certainly know we're all familiar with
the big change the Walgreens the CVS is
you know your big grocery stores your
Kroger's your big-box retailers
you know but this is also your
mom-and-pop independent pharmacies your
small-town pharmacy if you will in the
truth is most patients are going to
visit their pharmacy more often than any
other health care provider you know
certainly sometimes that's you know to
buy chewing gum or to a greeting card
but if we begin to think about how many
of those patients that come into the
pharmacy
even if they're not getting a
prescription filled are coming in
because they have an undiagnosed chronic
illness or a poorly managed chronic
illness or they're coming in for an
over-the-counter product because they
have an acute illness you know a cough
runny nose um so really you know the
pharmacist is an underutilized
healthcare resource and we'll talk a
little bit more about that as we
progress through so what are the
benefits of pharmacy testing in support
of clinical care really it starts and
ends with accessibility you know
pharmacies are you know they're known
for the convenient location some are 24
hours you know but most are open nights
and weekends it traditionally no one's
had to make an appointment to visit with
their pharmacist it's a walk-in service
model um you know if we expand this to
two patients without primary care
providers which by the way it's about a
third of adult Americans and certainly
as we get into some different
demographics that number shoots up even
higher but it's you know so patients who
really have no primary care provider no
medical home if you will
whose options really end up being
emergency and so that then leads pretty
quickly to lower costs if we can keep
somebody from going to the emergency
department for a routine illness that
saves everybody and as we move into some
of the new practice models that are
promoting team-based and
patient-centered care
again the pharmacy you know providing
care in the pharmacy setting really
makes a lot of sense whether that's the
accountable care organizations or the
patient-centered medical homes where you
know there's some risk sharing or
whether we talk about value-based
purchasing where we're trying to hit
some quality metrics or something as
simple as a high
deductible health plan where you know if
you're like most Americans in January
and February a visit to the physician's
office or a visit anywhere is really an
out-of-pocket expense so the opportunity
to kind of maximize the efficiency and
quality of care the pharmacy can
certainly play a role in that so how do
we eat us certainly there's there will
be some in in the audience we're
thinking immediately wait that's this is
not what pharmacists are trained to do
there there there this is outside of
their scope of practice really when we
start talking about some of the things
that pharmacists do in ambulatory care
settings and hospital settings in other
it comes down to protocols or
collaborative practice agreements that
really allow the pharmacists to play a
larger role as a part of that care
management team and really to support
primary care in chronic disease
management and acute illness care but
also in early detection of disease and I
think we all know that the earlier we
could detect a lot of these diseases you
know the better the outcomes the lower
the costs etcetera so again the role
that the pharmacist can play based on
that accessibility people will say well
this is radical this is crazy thinking
what are you talking about and you know
I did a simple google search just to
find out how far back could I find
evidence literature of pharmacists doing
point-of-care testing and so here you
know here's the example I found it's
from 1988 so over 30 years ago talking
about the establishment and evaluation
of cholesterol monitoring service in a
community pharmacy so so it's really not
a brand new idea and it's to be
completely honest it's not even that
rare of those 60,000 pharmacists or
pharmacies that I mentioned almost
11,000 so you know 16 17 percent of them
actually have laboratory designation
almost exclusively as CLIA waived
facilities right so they filled out that
that CLIA waiver and are able to do CLIA
way of testing
um so it's not particularly rare but
it's certainly not common so if we think
about what pharmacies have done to date
and what pharmacists have done today
there's a lot of pilot projects and you
know kind of academic studies or let's
try it in this market we've seen
pharmacies engage in screening events
and wellness fairs and those types of
things where they're doing you know for
instance a cholesterol screening you
know the second Saturday of every month
we've seen them do things under with
limited hours so it's a you know it's a
come in when this pharmacists is here or
when this staff member is here you know
sometimes it's not even the pharmacy
staff they're using special staffing
they're bringing in a nurse practitioner
or phlebotomist or whatever it is to
provide the testing service and that's
really you know that's that gets that
kind of the different ways we can think
about point of care testing in
pharmacies you know certainly we're
depending on where you live you're
probably familiar with the idea of the
pharmacy based retail clinic the Minute
Clinic you know we're staffed clinic run
by a nurse practitioner or physician's
assistant is providing some routine care
in the pharmacy and really that's yes
it's in the pharmacy but it is not by
the pharmacy or by the pharmacist this
is care provide you know in some ways
it's a little bit like having that
coffee shop inside of the big box
retailer it's kind of rented space and
certainly there's some synergies to it
but it's it's separately staffed and run
under a different agreement so that's
that is that is one way that we do see
pharmacies offering these types of
expanded clinical service you know
another way we see pharmacies involved
in point of care testing is the pharmacy
as the lab or specimen collection point
certainly there's a relatively famous or
infamous depending on where you how you
look at it example of this from a few
years back this was
fairness model again not necessarily the
pharmacist or the pharmacy staff
collecting the sample and certainly not
the pharmacy staff running the analysis
or doing anything with the results this
is really a kind of a pharmacy as
collection point if you will a specimen
collection and then send out the third
option and the one I guess for me at
least that's most exciting and in the
one that we've been involved with and
that I like to talk about is the one
where the pharmacists is actually
engaged in providing care you know so
this is the idea of a patient walking
into their pharmacy going back to the
pharmacy counter interacting with the
pharmacy staff the pharmacy technician
the pharmacist you know getting the test
run and then the pharmacist interacting
with the patient with the test results
providing you know whether it's under a
collaborative practice agreement
it's been taking medication for a strep
or linking somebody to care if they
scream positive or reactive rather for
for HIV or hepatitis C you know that's
that's kind of the model that stretches
to all 60,000 potentially of those
pharmacies but certainly you know back
to that specimen collection model we see
that happening we see that as certainly
as a convenience and an option to
increase kind of adherence to testing
and so there's certainly you know
there's probably a place for you know
across the board all three of these
models to coexist in certainly you see
some big players in both diagnostics and
and pharmacy engaged on all fronts
really when we talk about the pharmacy
base it's a collaborative disease
management program right it's really
about the pharmacists working as part of
a care team with you know pretty
specific goals to improve patient
outcomes through early detection and
early in appropriate interventions or
linkages to care to improve overall
public health through disease
surveillance and containment to improve
appropriate medication use so you know
one of the areas that pharmacists have
been engaged you know for decades but
certainly
last decade is an idea of medication
therapy management or MTM where
pharmacists are counseling patients on
all of the medications they're on and
making recommendations on starting new
therapies changing therapies working
again with the provider but the truth is
most community pharmacists doing this
have really limited information they
basically have the list of medications
right they don't have things like renal
function they don't have you know those
kind of lab values that pharmacists in
an ambulatory care or inpatient setting
have so you know the opportunity to to
kind of ramp this up to an MDM on
steroids if you will and then overall
can we reduce costs to health care
systems I so full disclosure I'm a I'm a
health economist by training so for me
you know how can we how can we begin to
shift needles and reduce ER visits and
hospitalizations because you know
picture here on the slide kills me you
know we we have emergency rooms that are
advertising their wait times which is
really about you know trying to get
patients in for non-emergency things and
we know that's that's the least
efficient care in terms of cost that we
could possibly providing so if we can if
we can move people from from those types
of settings into a pharmacy setting you
know again that's that's a win for
society that's so what are the
components of a successful disease
management program you know first and
foremost it's a partnership if it
doesn't come through clearly through the
rest but that starts right at the top
this is a it's a it's a partnership
between the pharmacy and the provider
certainly using the CLIA waived
point-of-care tests and I think on the
one of the previous slides I you know I
showed that ninety nine twenty five
percent of pharmacies that have you know
that are operating as laboratories are
doing so it's clear wave laboratories
and you know very few pharmacies are
going to have the inclination or you
know kind of the willingness or the
space whatever to go in to moderate
complexity or anything higher
than that it's really about these kind
of simple clear way of tests and how do
you utilize them as a tool in a
successful disease management program
and again I'll hit on that again and
again that we really just view these
tests as a is a piece of the puzzle not
the answer um then certainly it
it calls for trained personnel right we
certainly we know that clear wave tests
are meant to be so so easy to use you
know that an untrained individual can
use them but to take it to the specimen
collection and then ultimately to
following a protocol or algorithm to
provide the best possible care for the
patient that does require training that
does require education and so certainly
making sure that everybody involved in
offering these types of disease
management programs is appropriately
trained knows what to do you know I'm an
invalid test knows what to do for a
patient that comes in and it's
clinically unstable etc and then having
you know having a plan for patient
follow-up and I think it's you know the
easiest thing is to think about hey if a
patient comes in and they test positive
for group a strep what's the plan and
you know the plan is pretty
straightforward at that point its
dispensed amoxicillin or whatever the
appropriate antibiotic is or whatever
has been agreed on in the collaborative
practice you're in you know I think the
bigger question becomes what do you do
for a patient who tests negative
who comes into the pharmacy and so
having a plan for for follow-up with
that patient as well whether it's
providing you know counseling and
over-the-counter products to manage
symptoms making sure to follow up with
the patient in the next day or two to
see how they're doing having you know a
plan in place for referrals again if
somebody is clinically unstable but but
really what is the plan for patient
follow-up is an important piece of this
and then you know the last pieces is
data share you know and it links back up
to this idea of the partnership that the
pharmacy is not here to fragment care
the pharmacists is not here to provide
care on an island
so how do we make sure the encounter the
visit gets shared back with with the
appropriate providers whether you know
obviously the primary care provider if
the patient has won the collaborating
physician regardless in the case of
reportable diseases you know is it
getting to the appropriate public health
agencies all of that so the a successful
disease management program has a plan in
place for all of that so you know if we
think about it kind of a here I'll focus
on acute conditions you know thinking
influenza or a group a strep what it is
right what does that model kind of look
like with a goal on the far side there
have improved health outcomes right it
starts with the with a patient
assessment when I you know talk about
patient assessment you know certainly
that that includes physical assessment
that includes asking patient you know
medical history really with a goal of
identifying patients that are
appropriate to be seen in the pharmacy
setting because there are going to be
patients who are not there are going to
be patients who are clinically unstable
they're going to be patients that are
too complex there are going to be
patients for whatever what ever other
reason just shouldn't be seen in the
pharmacy and so that patient assessment
that says how do we how do we identify
them how do we identify patients who who
should be should be seen by another
provider and having a plan in place for
referral
it also means maximizing the value of
the test that you're gonna use right and
so it means how do we through this
assessment identify patients who who
truly need to be tested I think that may
be the simplest one is something like
influenza you know if there's no flu
activity in the community and it's the
middle of the summer it probably doesn't
make much sense to be testing for
influenza in the pharmacy saying excuse
me so having that all in place then
providing the tests of the patient
because again the test is just a piece
of that puzzle
and then having a plan in place whether
it be enabled through a collaborative
practice agreement in the cases where
pharmacists have some in some level of
independent prescribing being able to
take action on the results of the tests
so you know if you just do the patient
assessment in the point-of-care test and
then you provide that the patient with
the result and then say you know talk to
your physician I mean that really
doesn't provide a ton of value for the
patient you know the value is on being
able to contain it into that single kind
of visit if you will and so being able
to take action whether that means
dispensing medication or having a plan
in place to get that patient the
appropriate care with with very limited
hurdles for the patient and that so when
you bring all three of those together
that assessment that point of care test
and the ability to provide action on the
result of the tests through a
collaborative practice agreements or
protocol or other other means that's
what ultimately leads to the value of
improved outcomes in the pharmacy
setting my assumption as many in the in
the audience Florentino kind of the
requirements for obtaining a CLIA waiver
and so you know can a pharmacy get a
clear waiver and the answer is at the
federal level absolutely without
hesitation you know the only
requirements that waive laboratories
must me under CLIA is to enroll in the
CLIA program which is to fill out the
application pay the applicable
certificate fees by annually and I think
that's one hundred and fifty dollars and
then agree to follow manufacturer's test
instructions so that I mean that's it's
it's a very low bar in terms of who
could potentially be doing this type of
testing um you'll see there's no it
doesn't have to be a health care
provider it doesn't have to be health
care facility anything like that I mean
you know certainly if we if we think
about kind of the genesis of we're clear
waivers you know this was intended to be
you know for some community-based
screenings etc so so certainly
pharmacists can can obtain a clear
waiver at the federal level which is not
say that there aren't states that have
added some additional restriction so
that really becomes the the first of the
challenges associated with with pharmacy
based testing the state limitations on
what a pharmacy can do and so there are
there are a couple of states that
outright prevent pharmacies or
pharmacists from from holding CLIA
waivers you know they're they they have
quit additional requirements on
facilities and who can be a laboratory a
little bit more common is our states
that limit who can serve as a laboratory
director and again that's a small number
so I think you know be between those top
two you know we're talking about maybe
five states max maybe even less than
that now that's the other challenge of
this rules change pretty regularly so
there are some states who will limit
that a lab director must be a somebody
with a laboratory degree elaborate Orion
or a medical degree much more common is
limiting what tests can be performed so
there are probably you know round number
a hundred and twenty plus CLIA waived
tests available on the market you know
that have been approved at a federal
level there are states that have said
yeah but we don't recognize X lines and
so they have a much smaller subset I
think some state pick on anyone but I
think New Jersey maybe has the the most
limited set of tests that can be formed
can be performed in the pharmacy setting
I think it's it's it's under ten last
time I had looked so that that becomes a
limit and again that's that's a
relatively small number so I think you
know if you take those limitations
pharmacy based testing is still possible
in probably forty or so states for you
plus what then becomes the greatest
limiting factor is what can be done
under a collaborative practice agreement
with the test results or limiting the
testing to happening
under the order of a physician or
somebody else so that the pharmacist
cannot test a patient who walks in and
requests a test so you know again that
becomes a little bit of the challenge
associated with with rolling out
pharmacy based testing the second piece
of that is what can the pharmacists do
with the test and are they able to
prescribe based on the results of the
tests can they can they establish a
collaborative practice agreements a that
this is this slide is a this graphic is
a little bit dated things have changed a
little bit over time so 49 states
actually have some level of
collaborative practice law that allows
pharmacists in a community setting to to
change or dispense medications subject
to a collaborative practice agreements
so without without going back and
getting an individual prescription but
it varies very broadly on what I would
consider the most restrictive side they
are a collaborative practice agreement
for one physician one pharmacist one
patience in other words if you know
doctor Smith and pharmacist Jones are
treating patient Johnson they come to an
agreement that says if you know if this
medication is not working pharmacist
made just dose
pretty restrictive make some sense for
chronic disease management certainly you
know the ability of the pharmacist to
maybe change the cholesterol medication
or diabetes medication much much more
limited on acute disease so you know
these patients specific collaborative
practice agreements then we see the as
the continuum kind of broadens you know
it can be for any patient of this
physician and this pharmacy again kind
of limited and then really the the
states that offer probably the most
opportunity for the kind of services
that we're talking about allow a
pharmacists to dispense a new medic
for any patient who comes in who meets
certain clinical criteria so that's the
kind of collaborative practice agreement
where the physician and the pharmacist
would sit down and say you know here's
our protocol here's this here's this
clinical algorithm if you will and if
patient meets all of these criteria
pharmacists run this test if the result
is positive do you exit if result is
negative you why and so those are and
that's the model that's probably
available in about 17 states that allow
that kind of level of pharmacist
engagement pharmacist collaboration we
now see states going beyond that we do
see some states that are allowing
pharmacies or pharmacists to do
independent prescribing for certain
disease states we see it for things like
birth control we see it for things like
naloxone we're also seeing statewide
protocols that are saying you know okay
you no longer have to go out and find
that collaborator if you as pharmacists
agreed to follow the state protocol then
you may dispense this medication so
really again it becomes it's the
challenge and as you might imagine it's
a particular challenge if you're a
pharmacy that operates in multiple
states because you were you know that
you need to basically set up a different
model for every state in which you
operate you know additional challenges
associated with pharmacy based testing
are probably not unique to the pharmacy
some of them probably maybe are but you
know just like everything else every
everywhere else where testing occurs
test performance and other limitations
the sensitivity and specificity of the
tests I mean we all know that you're
doing a CLIA wave test you you know a
point-of-care test if you will there's
there's probably some trade-off to what
happens in a central lab and you know
we're we're trading off turnaround time
we're trading off complexity we're
trading off cost etc
but that means probably some reduction
in test performance and sensitivity and
specificity certainly you know we've
seen incredible progress in the
development of these tests we've seen
these tests become you know much higher
quality we're seeing you know as
happened with the influenza test here
over the last year or so you know we're
seeing some additional requirements to
kind of maintain that quality but you
know that becomes the challenge in the
pharmacy setting and so how do you you
know how do you maximize the
characteristics of these tests which by
the way I mean these are the same tests
that are being used in other settings so
you know so when somebody says well why
would you be using this test in a
pharmacy and I it's the same test that
gets used in physicians offices clinics
etc but it but it does point back to
having that strong protocol in place
that's strong you know other elements of
physical assessment and knowing what to
do with a patient regardless of test
results storage requirements for you
know it doesn't make a lot of sense in a
pharmacy setting you know with a locking
model to have a test that has to be
brought out of a freezer or brought to
room temperature minutes you know to ask
the patient to sit around for two hours
does it make sense because you know
quite honestly most of these pharmacies
just the volume of testing isn't high
enough to kind of justify so storage
requirements matter you know expiration
dates etc um cost matters a little bit
more about this but down below but the
idea that for most pharmacies this is
still a cash paid business so running a
test that cost you know five hundred
dollars just doesn't make sense this
pharmacy visit that we're talking about
um you know unless we get into something
more complex maybe some pharmacogenomics
genetics testing so we're you know it
has to be a relatively modest investment
in terms of the cost of the test the
size matters I mean most pharmacies have
very limited space very limited patient
counseling space
[Music]
the big closet rather than you know
giant exam room and so you know even
something the size of a breadbox know if
you have to have two or three of those
that takes up a lot of pretty valuable
and linseed so it it's important that
the size is appropriate to the pharmacy
setting I'm finding a willing
collaborator when we collaborating
provider certainly is going to be a
challenge for a lot of pharmacies a lot
of pharmacists um there are a lot of we
certainly in our experience we've had a
lot of physicians who are very very
supportive infectious disease doctors
public health primary care providers who
see kind of this is the future and the
benefit certainly amongst laboratorians
as well but the truth is there are also
some who will view this as a bit of a
turf issue they're going to say hey you
know I guess if you're testing them in
the pharmacy that means they're not
coming to my you know my office and I
miss out on that's you know that's
that's something I miss out on there are
others who are gonna say you know what
this is just beyond the scope of what of
what a pharmacist should be doing so the
challenge is and finding that willing
collaborating provider you know I hotel
you these next two are are the questions
or the the challenges I get from
pharmacy from pharmacists the the first
isn't workflow and people will say you
know I'm really busy and if you've ever
been in you know to your average
pharmacy it's kind of controlled chaos
back there and certainly you know they
are they are busy people doing doing
lots of things just you know just
dispensing medications the minds is
generally quite high so how do you how
do you fit something like this into
workflow and you know the way I always
turn it back to the pharmacist is I
talked about where pharmacists are with
immunizations but you know if you think
about flu shots 20 years ago pharmacies
provided probably you know a scant if
any flu shot certainly in some states
they weren't doing it at all
and now pharmacists provide about a
quarter of all flu shots every year and
they fit that into the workflow well I
mean they developed a workflow around it
and they made it a priority and in just
like that that's how you would develop a
service like this we've done some time
and motion studies and I mean it's it
does fit into the workflow it's actually
a relatively modest time commitment by
the pharmacist you know especially if
you have good technicians who can you
can handle some of the backend things in
a can fit in the workflow I mean there
are challenges it has to be thought
through it you know how do you patients
who come into the pharmacy with
influenza you know you certainly want to
keep them away from other patients okay
I have had people push back and say look
we don't want sick people in pharmacies
and people sick people come into
pharmacies every single day I mean
that's that's where they go now we have
an opportunity to identify them and help
them and so you know just just figuring
out those types of things is all part of
that workflow that works in the pharmacy
and then payment and sustainability
certainly this is a business offering it
is a something that you do in a
sustainable manner spend a ton of time
on it I mean I think there are there are
certainly insurance companies and
third-party payers who recognize kind of
that cost-saving element that efficiency
that value of doing this in pharmacy but
you know like any new service where as
we as we move away from a
fee-for-service kind of landscape the
focus probably needs to be on providing
a service that patients value and are
willing to pay for and I think certainly
in our experience and with the
pharmacies that we work for when they
focus on that they've had no trouble
getting patients to pay for these types
of services because you know patients
value accessibility their convenience
you know I always tell the story that my
my kids were never told that they're
only supposed to be sick between 9:00
and 3:30 Monday through Thursday you
know they get sick at all hours in the
day and night and
so certainly there's some value to us of
having that that convenient care and I
think that's it's played out by the rise
in the number of urgent cares and
expanded hours for clinics etc so how do
we demonstrate value and those improve
patient outcomes and so I certainly the
need for additional studies the
additional recording of kind of outcomes
and etc this is this is a relatively new
area but it's certainly there's it's
right for additional study but the truth
is it's also I think other people much
smarter than me have looked at this and
said you know there's opportunity here
and so I refer to this 2015 report from
from Deloitte I'm talking about the
opportunities for pharmacy based point
of care testing and really what they
said is the point of care testing
services are anticipated to surpass
immunizations to drive revenue you know
for all of the reasons I've discussed so
I think that when when that kind of
report comes out it certainly gets the
attention of the pharmacy chains and the
pharmacies and I think then there
becomes a an interest in implementing
and looking at what kind of offerings
what kind of disease management programs
can be put in place and so and I won't
spend a ton of time talking about you
know we've done some working in
community pharmacies in the u.s. around
group a strep we've done it around
influenza and really what we I think
what we've been able to demonstrate in
those is that that pharmacies can in
fact fit this into their workflow they
can in fact manage patients without any
kind of complications there's very
limited follow-up the patient outcomes
are are high in patient satisfaction is
very high and I think you know which is
not shocking because people trust their
pharmacist but the idea that we were
dispensing an antibiotic to only about
11 15 percent of patients coming in
seeking group a strep test which is well
below the national average but still had
a really high
a patient satisfaction rate and I ate
that to communication upfront setting
expectations with with the patient
letting them know what was going to
happen and that that would be follow up
likewise you know we only dispensed
timethere antiviral to about eleven
percent of the patients which is and
none of those patients got an antibiotic
which compares very favorably to kind of
national averages we're about 30 percent
of patients with influenza end up
getting an antibiotic which is no it's
completely inappropriate for the most
part um certainly others have done
studies as well and I apologize just
went to the back but Kingdom showing
basically the same types of things so I
think there's there's generally an
acceptance that there's that this can
work in pharmacies it's been
demonstrated now in multiple countries
as well so really what are the
opportunities then for pharmacy basic
point of care testing and I think looted
to a lot of these throughout you know
chronic disease management prevention
whether that's you know something like
cholesterol or hemoglobin a1c for
diabetes you know and I'm potential or
an opportunity to affect a large patient
population certainly when we talk about
these two disease states we know it
affects millions of millions of
Americans and there are clearly defined
guidelines for treatment and goals
pharmacists have been doing these types
of things for decades in a dilatory
clinic settings
you know pharmacists and utilized
collaborative practice here and so
really it's about it's about kind of
taking that same model that has worked
for for a number of years in an
ambulatory setting in expanding it to
community settings because the truth is
you know most ambulatory clinics just
aren't going to be able to afford to
have a full-time pharmacist there so can
we can we get some of that same value in
in the community setting the minor acute
illnesses that I've talked about you
know whether it's influenza pharyngitis
or RSV or any number of other operatory
infections or you know the the fact is
patients already
care for these illnesses in their
pharmacy now it's about giving the
pharmacist tools and a collaborative
practice agreement that allows them to
better manage those patients - you know
instead of just pointing to the coffin
hole dial to manage symptoms it's about
getting at the kind of the underlying
illness and so the CPA that can allow
for complete management a pharmacy for
the appropriate populations you know
among other things that it has through
the potential to relieve the burden on
primary care providers let's let's let
primary care providers focus on the more
complex patients the you know the
chronic illnesses those but really need
a little bit more time and attention um
and then you know opportunities around
Public Health we've done some work in
HIV and hepatitis C screening so a
number of others you know despite all
the talk about both there's still a
great need for screening there's still a
great need to get patients who are
screened and do have a reactive test
linked for confirmatory testing and
reporting to public health and that's
all somewhere where pharmacies are well
positioned certainly if we talk about
something like HIV and pre exposure
prophylaxis programs or programs you
know pharmacies are really well situated
as a matter of fact we're you know HIV
clinics really just aren't set up to
manage patients who are exposed but not
who don't yet have HIV so this is a way
you know working together that the
pharmacy can manage some of that and
then you know things happen we we did
some work in Flint Michigan around blood
testing we're digging too deep into it
you know there are some submissions in
the water in Flint and the need for
additional access points for lead
testing and we were able to move very
quickly once we got the okay and you
know worked with the manufacturer and
with the pharmacies we were able to have
site set up in pharmacies to do lab
testing in a number of weeks
and so you know really kind of a way for
pharmacy to engage on a public health
level and also at a community level so
you know there's certainly a number of
opportunities and I know there are
there's a move afoot
you know from wholesalers and others to
move pharmacy point-of-care testing
programs forward really you know so I as
I wrap up here and talk about you know
it is still early days I some you're in
something is kind of deeply as I've been
over the last decade you forget that
sometimes you think it should be much
further along but pharmacy based point
of care testing is still in its early
days the interest in momentum moving
towards widespread adoption is there I
think from the pharmacy side they you
know going back to the Deloitte report
there's certainly a view that this could
be the next immunization from the kind
of the diagnostic manufacturers I mean
this is a this is an opportunity this is
a kind of a new market if you will but
you know I think more broadly this is an
opportunity to improve patient care this
is an opportunity to work together and
kind of the landscape of 2018 and going
forward how we're going to deliver care
to patients where they need it when they
need it you know in a fair and
reasonable cost and so really you know
continued efforts are needed to help
reduce those barriers to get us to that
water implementation so with that I will
go ahead and stop and see if there any
questions thank you doctor cluster for
that informative port presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button answer as many
of your questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
our pharmacists trained to use these
tests
and or interpret the results yeah that's
that's a great question so without going
too deep into kind of pharmacy education
in 2018 so so pharmacists you know the
the pharmd became the entry-level degree
the doctorate degree came the
entry-level degree in about 2000 and
really it's a even before that but but
certainly at that time there was kind of
a shift in pharmacy education in
pharmacy training to include a lot more
of this kind of clinical physical
assessment some you know some diagnostic
testing that said it's there's probably
some variation across the country the
National Association of chain drugstores
actually kind of to address that issue
for their members but also has developed
a point of care training certificate
program that is really about you know
well beyond just you know how do you do
a nasal swab to you know how do you
develop and interpret a result and set
up one of these disease management
programs so I would say you know
certainly this for most pharmacists that
becomes refresher for what they what
they got in their schooling but yeah I
I'm quite confident that pharmacists are
trained and prepared to do this our next
question is every time I go into a
pharmacy the pharmacist seems busy how
would the pharmacists have time for this
yes a great question and I think I refer
to it in the presentation a little bit
yeah I mean that's that's the number one
challenge and again it's how do we
prioritize and I think the other the
other thing if we think about kind of
pharmacy in general and where things are
going is there's a there's quite a move
afoot to to relieve the pharmacists some
responsibilities in the dispensing
function you know we have things like
technician check technician we have
things like robots and automation in
central fill and and all of these other
things really which are designed to free
up the pharmacists to do more of the
types of things so you know I think what
you're going to see and I in a you know
it started with immunizations but I
think what you're going to see is
pharmacists having more time for
medication therapy management pharmacist
having more time for diagnostic
screenings and testings and these types
of disease management programs and
really not only will they have more time
I think there's going to be more of an
expectation that that's how they're
filling their day so I think that it's a
great question and this won't work in
all pharmacies I mean I'll be the first
person to admit that there are gonna be
some pharmacies that are just you know
they are too busy to do this but again
just as they were able to fit
immunizations in this does fit into a
workflow if thought about carefully
absolutely and going forward I think
that's going to become even more obvious
and dr. Clough sir what looks like we
have time for one more question
many of these point-of-care tests have
limitations on their performance how our
pharmacists trained to handle that yeah
certainly so you know so again back to
the training you know the pharmacists
are are going through in their you know
certainly when we trained pharmacists we
train them on you know understanding the
limitations of the test and that the
test is written just a tool as part of a
disease management program and so that
becomes part of it that collaboration
with with a physician or other provider
and saying okay you know here's the test
we're going to use you you know this is
the sensitivity and specificity if we do
these things you know and only test this
population we know we can get to a you
know a higher positive or negative
predictive value but what do we do with
that patient that potential false
negative patients or that potential
false positive patient and that's where
the protocol that's where the the
algorithm has to have okay you know what
kind of follow-up are we gonna have what
kind of what kind of symptomatic
management are we gonna provide you know
when does that patient need to be
referred you know certainly if we if we
get into something like pandemic where
you know the expectation you know where
the CDC or others recommend
treating patients for influenza based on
science and symptoms well then you know
then it then it's let's revisit what the
protocol looks like but it's it's having
a plan in place and then you know then
it's just about the pharmacist following
that plan and that really is the
important kind of takeaway at least when
we train is knowing what you're going to
do because there there may you know you
you might not be perfect we're gonna do
everything we can to maximize value but
but understanding what are we gonna do
to make sure that even if we're wrong
that patient you know suffers no will
because of it I would like to once again
thank dr. klipse R for his impressive
prep for his presentation I would also
like to thank leverage for making
today's educational webcasts possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2018 you will receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye